- Anna Maria Tremonti,
CBC News, Moscow.
Jerusalem.
London.
Washington.
- C'est une s s journalistes
les plus réputées et les plus
primées au Canada.
Elle a couvert la chute
de l'Union soviétique...
- The fact that this is
a jewi h holiday...
- ... le conflit israélo-
palestinien et les guerres
dans l'ex-Yougoslavie.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Th f flee their home and head
to a town they think is safe.
- Anna Maria Tremonti racontait
la détresse des victimes de ces
conflits, avec une empathie
particulière pour les femmes
violées et torturées.
Aujourd'hui, elle prend le micro
pour raconter son histoire.
♪ ♪ ♪
Quand elle a eu l'idée de ce
balado, la journaliste pensait
écrire une bonne nouvelle :
elle s'en était bien sortie,
aiaiaiait eu une belle carrière,
la blessure était refermée,
croyait-elle. Mais écrire
les assauts de son mari
a été un choc.
♪ ♪ ♪
Elle décrit crûment quelques
agressions pour tenter
de comprendre, d'expliquer
le cycle pernicieux
de la violence conjugale.
Comme bien des victimes
d'lelelelelelents,
la journaliste accepte
la version de son mari.
À chaque agression, il lui
répète que c'est de sa faute,
lelelelelele qui le provoque.
Pendant un an, Anna Maria prend
soin de cacher ses marques,
ses ecchymoses, elle ne dit
rien de sa détresse à quiconque.
Elle a honte d'avoir choisi
le mauvais mari, mais en même
temps, elle continue de croiree.
Une semaine après cet
ultimatum, elle retourne
vers lui, en quête d'une
réconcéaéaéaéaéaéaéaéagit
violemment. Trois jours
plus tard, la journaliste
a sa première entrevue à CBC.
♪ ♪ ♪
Ces hommes anéantissent
l'estime de soi de leurs
victimes. An
que si elle était une meilleure
épouse, son mari cesserait
de la frapper. Cette incapacité
à se défendre, à quitter
un conjoututututututututute
à la honte. L'animatrice dit
à ces femmes : "Vous n'êtes pas
coupables."
Anna Maria Tremonti rompt
le silence, aujourd'hui,
parce qu'elle souhaite quesususe
conjugale ne soient pas hantées
par ce dégoût de soi. Car même
enfouie sous les succès
d'une carriè
la honte a continué de faire mal
pendant 40 ans.